Tom Daley he was probably my biggest
inspiration like I literally had a
poster of not of him like posing like
because that would be weird
yeah yeah I do this a lot but he was in
like a little Pike show
um
he knows this already it's fine
now I've got a you know I've got a photo
of me and him together now I forgotmail
which is quite a cool little
I guess story
[Music]
when and why did you just decide to
become an athlete I didn't really enjoy
Primary School too much I wasn't very
like my education wasn't great I mean it
was a good place where I went to but I
just wasn't that smart
um and I was quite energetic as a kid
and I think my parents just wanted to
put me in like I remember doing all
sorts I remember doing gymnastics diving
Aikido yeah I think I just didn't really
enjoy sitting down in the chair and
doing
you know writing or maths or English or
anything like that
um so I think that's the main reason why
I became I guess an athlete I can
connect to that as well like I struggle
with Theory and Academia and when I was
at school I found it very hard to
concentrate I was sort of a fidgeting
are sitting you're moving around and
because of the bullying and things like
that and I wasn't very good with hand
and eye coordinated Sports
I found cycling and swimming and that's
how I got involved to become an athlete
and I wanted to do something where I had
a purpose in life and it's seen as Keira
rather than Kira being naughty or not
paying attention or seen as yes you have
a disability so you can't do anything in
life
I mean I'm lucky I guess that I had a
mum who chose cycling as a form of
losing weight because I wasn't really
that good at other sports as such but
she happened to choose cycling and that
happened to be the one that I was good
at yeah I was like that because I was I
don't ever feel like I kind of seeked
out sport probably similar to yourself
but I just tried a 16 year Sprint one
day I don't know if you were the same
and just somebody told me that you might
be quite good at it so yeah we just um
took it seriously started training and
that was that I think I was just I was
just like a sporty kid like I was like I
walked at seven months um and I feel
like my mom was like just get her doing
something so I was like a dancer I was a
gym now so I played football I played
hockey eventually I found cycling which
wasn't by choice
and that was more like a that was when I
was getting back from my stroke like I
just got onto a bike because I couldn't
run
um and then someone was like oh you're
kind of good at this like let's do some
testing and yeah that was it yeah
everyone I I realized when I could
represent a Great Britain well games and
and that's that's the moment when I
yeah
would become an athlete and it gave me
something to work towards as well what
was the journey like from starting in
sport for you
to going on to represent your country it
was one of those situations that I don't
know if you can all relate but when
you're younger in sport it's almost like
naivety you don't realize what you're
doing and it's not until you get older
as an asset that the pressure starts to
come and you start to realize where you
actually are and that you have taken it
to quite an elite level you know 19 year
old Johnny at 2012 had no clue where he
was he didn't ever realize that he was
at a paralympic games he didn't realize
that there was this pressure there was
this elitism I just kind of love
sprinting you know I had some blocks and
and ran the seriousness kind of came
later almost it was the enjoyment that
brought me brought me to it first and
that makes sense you know when you're
starting off it's a interesting and fun
experience that excitement the nerves
are going because you hoped all the
training and everything and that effort
and the support around you you really
hope that it pays off and you end up
getting that goal that you want and when
I first
started at cycling I couldn't ride a
bike at the age of 12. I couldn't handle
the breaks the bike the gears the
balance everything that was asked so I
kind of went away from that
and then I so happened to go to the
Village room where there's no breaks
sounds scary and then that's how I
learned how to ride the bike and other
people they start the other way around
do you find that there is um
like a point in our in your career it
goes from like fun and passion to like
almost obviously it's always not always
fun but does it get to a point where
it's like this is like tough Like You
Know It's a Grind every day and it's
like kind of like it's not as fun as it
used to be yeah I mean I definitely had
that like in between 2012 and 2016. 2012
definitely changed my life like there
was no two ways about it just the media
attention like even just being in the
public all of a sudden people knew who I
was and so it was very different and so
the build up for 2016 was so different
and like there was a good
I'd say 18 months post 2012 where I'd
achieved everything that I ever wanted
to and at the time I couldn't imagine
anything better I like everything like
as cliche as is it was like yeah your
dreams have come true and I was like
well what next like um got anything else
to win like I've won it now and so yeah
I spent like 18 months just
I guess working out like how I sort of
saw my career going from that point
onwards I would say that post-olympics
bit I really struggled with yeah that's
how I felt after Tokyo like I was like
oh bloody I've done it like I've my
first one like Tom like Tom hate it
because he would always say to me he's
like I've been trying this is my fourth
Olympics and I've been trying to go in a
nice way he wasn't making me feel like
an idiot he was like yeah yeah you just
don't own your first song great yeah
which is quite funny but um yes
obviously after after the Olympics when
went on I'm a celeb as well with kadina
and like I don't know my life felt very
different all of a sudden
um and it was great and I loved it and
then the big drop off and that that
didn't happen to me I said the post
Olympic depression it didn't happen to
me after the games happened to me after
I'm a celeb because I remember
getting vote well leaving the show and
then the next day I was back in back in
London training and I was just like I
don't really enjoy this like everything
felt like
because everything was so heightened
before now everything just felt really
dull boring nothing actually excited me
in like training as well like I really
didn't enjoy it and then when you've had
a I don't know when you've had a taste
and a for the fun like celebrity stuff
it's like well I said yeah love that
um you know but um you love diamonds
left yeah yeah yeah and then and then
eventually you know and that sort of
stuff stops and you're like oh like and
I felt like people kind of almost forgot
you know I think every four years it's
like like these people are amazing and
then like in between as you're saying
like they're in between period is like
the toughest part and obviously we're
kind of in that point now and I feel
like now we are kind of coming up to
Paris and hopefully things kind of gotta
be more fun again you guys kind of kept
kind of showing it with your hands as
well is that everything's easy on the
rise you know I mean once you're kind of
climb in the mountain it's all fun and
then once you get to the top of the
mountain you love it and then literally
is it's like day after the Olympics they
even want any setbacks you're kind of
going down yeah and you realize that
yeah and nothing kind of comes in you
guys obviously like straight into I'm a
celeb like these are big things that
you've got they've got these huge
focuses so you're literally almost going
up and up and up and then your brain's
just got nothing like do you guys get
that as well I didn't
really have have fun but
have fun
yeah it's difficult to have that bounce
back so in 2015 I didn't really know you
know I was
70 and going off to hopefully get some
medals and then next four years okay now
we know who you are so now we know what
you can do and then I guess that is that
trying to balance people's expectations
yeah I'm the same like I think you've
all said it like when you go from
essentially being a no one and then like
overnight everyone knows who you are
um because I went to I'd only just
started really in like disabled or
Parliament sport
um in 2015 so I went to 2016 and it's
like you know this kid that's just gonna
rock up and do some Sport and then it
goes well and you're like oh this is
cool and then you know you come out and
like oh go and do this TV show go to
this award sorry go on this red carpet
and it's like wow this is really cool
and I was literally just like I don't
know I felt like my head was actually
just like this and I was like enjoying
like every moment this is really cool
like you know you won the red carpet
with all these like amazing people and
it is really hard to like you know
bounce back and I think it was mentioned
earlier I was the same um I guess as you
you know coming from you know that high
of being good and then you know 2020 or
2021 everyone has this expectation that
Kadin is going to go and you know
compete really well and I found that
really hard like it was quite nice going
into 2016 as a nobody because there's no
expectations
but then 2021 everyone's like oh she's
gonna go and do this you know you do TV
adverts and people just know your face
and then it's like oh gosh the pressure
and I really felt the pressure and I was
injured before and I spent pretty much
every athletic session just crying and I
guess you know how hard it is when
you've when you've got an Athletics
injury like you get on the bike so that
was fine I was really good on the bike
but I just couldn't run so I was just
crying like day in day out
um just because I felt like I was going
to let everyone down and let myself down
and then you go to the games and it goes
all right and you're like okay I'm back
then you have to come down off that
Cliff again it's a bit of a it's a
roller coaster of four years because
it's just frustratingly like a lot of
people just see us as people that go to
the Olympics and Paralympics and in
between you know we just do nothing
we're just starting a coffee
what's the best part of being an athlete
I think my proudest moment I've ever
been an athlete isn't necessarily
winning winning the gold at Tokyo I
think
um like I remember when I was younger
like when I was when I first started
diving I was like seven years old and
like whenever the older divers like the
good divers ever made time for me you
know didn't just like ignore me as I was
walking by like hello sort of thing like
they would actually be like oh hello
like you know take the time out their
day to like and I looked up to them and
like weirdly I looked up to Tom even
though he was like still young like I
was literally a fan of of his and he
always was really nice and then it's
just weird how it all turned out
eventually but um
yeah I think whenever like the little
little divers just like I don't know
like you just look up to you and just
think whenever you see their smile
whenever you say hello to them I I I
it's that's when I'm most priorities
because it's like you know they they
think you are like some rock star and I
just like I love kind of inspiring the
younger the younger generation I guess
that's my proudest kind of obviously
winning the gold was was very good
yeah yeah I had this conversation it's
quite funny just listening to that
because like I still have I don't know
if you guys I've had like imposter
syndrome so like I'm at the track at
Leicester sometimes and I it's a track
that I go to kind of on my own sometimes
when I need to just kind of focus on
myself but sometimes if the club's there
I feel like people stare and a lot of
time I literally I almost feel like
they're trying to stare at me like what
are you doing here like that and I'm
sitting there like why are these people
staring at me like that like and it's
like should I am I on your way so I'm
always trying to like move out the way
and stuff and it wasn't until the other
day because my girlfriend gets her nails
done by someone who's basically
boyfriend goes to the track and they're
like oh yeah he was there the other day
and I saw him and I didn't want to go up
to him and I was like is that why people
obviously are looking at me but I'm like
thinking that they're just like staring
me down I kind of don't see myself in
that light a lot of time it's like I
automatically probably see it as like
I'm just this guy who's in the way right
it's just I don't know if any of you I
feel like it's like that imposter
syndrome type thing I don't know if you
ever
and you guys have moments like that yeah
I'm a bit like that I feel like you'll
speak to someone like for instance you
know like a doctor and I'm like you
seriously do something that's like well
better than me like but I do love it
when you know like you get like kids
coming up to you and they're like um
actually I've got an opportunity here
like to be able to like impact their
life I've got
um a couple of kids that I help support
at the moment and seeing them come onto
the GB team is like the best thing ever
and like I literally I was on the track
yesterday on one of my Riders was on
there and I just I was like riding
around just so proud like it's cool what
we do but like what we can do outside of
that is like so much bigger and that's
what I find like is what makes me proud
of what I've done if I make sense I mean
for me I'm like experiencing it
firsthand I think a bit like because
obviously I'll be my little boy is fun
with and um it's funny because like when
I look back I just think
sport has literally given me everything
my British cycling has pretty much given
me everything like I'm a product of the
system but obviously from that I've got
a husband my sister works for them
um I I feel like they're a second family
to me like they've been incredible and
obviously now I've got Alby and he goes
to me the other day and now this is a
five-year-old right and he's like Mommy
when can I have a bike with skinny
wheels and I'm like skinny Wheels like
and it didn't even occur to me that
obviously he's looking at a road bike or
a track bike all the time thinking well
I don't want this mountain bike like I
want what they've got like that makes me
so proud that he's looking at what mummy
and daddy do and he's like I want to do
that and like I would never push him
down the cycling route well it's not
that I wouldn't it's just he's always
going to have that expectation of being
Laura and Jason's son but
just the fact that he's gone wow like
what they do is really fun can I do that
just makes me sit there and go oh like
that's an achievement in itself really
he has been pretty cool parents it's
always good enough that's a lot of
pressure like I can hear the commentator
now
[Music]
practice moments
representing my country basket on and
went in a gold medal
what made you change the cycling because
you've already got a gold medal in
basketball yeah
[Music]
different
experience of in a in a new sport and
and also have a chance yes
get into another world games as well
which one's harder yeah
[Laughter]
yeah yeah good answer once you've
started on a journey and you've
succeeded in winning a gold medal what
was that like what's the emotion like
for me I'm like I literally spend day in
day out you know working to run you know
60 seconds or cycle 35 seconds which is
actually not then but like you do all
that hard work and in that moment it's
like oh like I've literally done it but
it's such a short period of time that
you're just like it's kind of over I get
that I do get that and I guess you
always want that moment to lengthen and
I guess for me it was when I was given
the medal around my neck but also when I
go into schools and I talk to the
children about
having a dream and if you've got a goal
you can achieve it and don't let anybody
tell you any different and for some
children they need that reminder of you
are amazing you are fabulous you can
succeed even if you have barriers that
unfortunately are put in your way and
when they say something okay I'll quick
medals or fabulous ago what do you want
to see you want you at home we go yeah
like you just see it all over the face
and I think it's that moment of wow I've
met somebody who's like me and who
understands me and I'm not alone anymore
you know I feel like the medals are more
for like other people than they are for
like me like you have that moment
obviously win the medal but I feel like
yeah it's them for like other people
does anyone else like get that like all
those they got stolen I'd be very upset
reminded me to maybe check my drawer
because I haven't actually looked at it
yeah I feel like they do kind of just
get pick up dust on the side or in a
drawer like it's weird no mine is I do
place it like pretty much straight in my
living room but that's the only I live
in London but my family all live in
Leeds and like my own Leeds I've got
like a big cabinet on my important
medals uh but yeah my mum and dad used
to hate it but I the gold medal is the
only one I have with me
wherever I am yeah it's the important
one but I remember the feeling of when
me and Tom found out
I felt this like superhuman power where
I like hugged Tom and like picked him up
and he felt as light as a feather
um and then I remember falling to the
ground
um and it was like I wasn't crying
because no no tears was coming from my
eyes but you know like the you know the
kind of how you breathe when you cry it
was like that but it just felt like a a
release of all like all the pressure
over the years and all the hard work and
then I remember at the back of the
podium crying properly because I
remember thinking my all my family my
friends are all in like my garden in
Leeds actually I didn't know they were
there but I just knew that they were
obviously watching at home and I was
like yeah like I've done the proud it
was Los Angeles
[Music]
it made me yeah
proud and honored
and and just just just being there as
it was just amazing and Serena at the
moment as well
and yeah because it was uh
didn't skip bar just enjoyed it
um yeah I mean obviously 2012 for me
didn't come easy because there's no
Olympic medal as easy as it but
I was a kid I was 20 I was young for a
cyclist no one knew who I was and I just
sort of fell at it and then you go you
win
but then it changed for me in terms of
expectation and for me the biggest thing
was and like no pressure I didn't want
to be a one-hit wonder I wanted to prove
that I could come back and do it it
wasn't fluke I didn't fluke it like I
went there I was at my very best at the
time and I wanted to prove that I could
get back to that and that was what
motivated me for those next four years
saying you didn't want to be a one-hit
wonders one thing going out and trying
to do it all over again like was a
complete other thing
um and all while now being under the
spotlight because obviously people then
did know who I was so it was just a very
different experience
um but then between 2016 and Tokyo
by this point but like my whole thing
with that was I hadn't sacrificed all
this time with my little boy
to not go and achieve the end goal and
when I look back
would the sacrifice of leaving Alby at
home all this time not even at home
because he traveled the world with us
but just like the sacrifice of the
training sessions and the training comes
would it have been worth it if we hadn't
have won like honestly I don't know like
because that little boy is like my
everything like he's my world and so it
had to be worth it at the end and the
sacrifices that you have to make that
not everybody gets
unless you're an athlete they don't get
it you know it's early starts late
nights making sure you're eating the
correct foods that you've been suggested
to it making sure that you're having
enough rest and it's also applying
yourself in those situations where
sometimes you might be thinking what's
the point it's not going to benefit me
for me you kind of put there what I
actually think is the hardest thing
about being an athlete which is that I
don't for me at least I don't look at my
day as the hard work I actually love
going and training it's not that hard
for me I feel like genuinely someone
said to me sit down behind this computer
and work for 10 hours that would be 10
times worse than going and being sick at
a lactic session but going home and not
having the ability to switch off I think
that for me is what I think actually is
the hardest part about that sacrifice of
being an athlete everyone always assumes
it's the really gritty hard work which I
think some people do struggle with but
it is that it's every night going I've
got to go to bed I've got to make sure
that I get enough sleep I can't eat this
food in case it inflames me I can't go
to this event and because I'm going to
sit down and drive you know for for six
hours and it's weird I don't know when
you say like that it just it makes me
recognize that at least from everyone
else's perspective it's like they
sometimes think the hard works are
really hard work but don't do you guys
feel like that I feel like that's
actually the easiest part of my job at
least yeah or it's 24 7 and it like
being an athlete is 24 7 who's inspired
you in your career do you know I used to
be really inspired by um
an athlete called Alison Felix who I
just think she's great like she just
runs so elegantly she can do the 100 the
200 the 400 and be great at all of them
and then like she does like loads of
great advocacy I used to think she was
great am I a real kind of yeah like Hero
whatever growing up I guess was actually
Victoria Pendleton because as cyclists
it's not like football is it like the
the when Alby watches football he's
watching he thinks that they're behind a
screen like he doesn't he doesn't
associate them as being people as such
because they're massively famous and you
can't go on train with them where's
Vicky for me she was at all these bike
races like her dad used to set up these
graphs track events which we used to go
to and so it as much as she was an idol
she was also a person that you could go
and speak to and she would help you so
it was just a very yeah I'd say like
we're lucky I guess in that in that
sense that these Idols you can actually
go and speak to and meet and they're
approachable for me I mean that I I had
met my own path
as as there aren't many uh famous people
with an intellectual disability because
there was no one
um to like look up to like your mission
I'm guessing is to be that for someone
else that you are Paving their way which
I think is really good really helpful
yeah yeah
my first inspiration in diving was a
diver called Greg Louganis and then
eventually like well quickly it became
Tom Daly he was uh probably my biggest
inspiration and I remember you know
watching Tom at the uh 2008 Olympics
um and thinking like bloody hell like
he's done it at 14. that's kind of crazy
um so I remember going on my first uh
competition that we all go to a
condition as a team and uh Tom Tom was
on the team it was 2012. um it was my
first ever junior junior World
Championships and he was on it and so
was I think like four other Olympians as
well so I was like this is crazy like
this is I was like the youngest you
could be and I like I remember he um he
retweeted my tweet I sat there with my
dad at home like refreshing my my
Twitter profile
loads of followers like I think I
reached a thousand followers and back
then I remember thinking like oh my God
this is so cool
um and yeah that was like the first time
I ever like properly like you know went
on a team with with Tom and it was it
was it was funny and obviously I I
remember asking him for like sign photos
even though I was on a team with me
probably thought I was a loser
um but he was super nice and then you
know now we're our Olympic or malistia
which is actually like a I don't know
it's really cool for me because like
going from one like I literally had a
poster of not of him like posing like
that because that would be weird
yeah yeah I do this a lot but he was in
like a little Pike Shake
okay
he knows this already it's fine
um but yeah and then then now I've got a
fit you know I've got a photo of me and
him together now I forgotmail which is
quite a cool little I guess story who do
you think has been the most influential
on you in your career
uh it's probably I'm sure you guys will
probably say similar things but the most
influential person has to be my coach uh
down path uh who I moved to in 2012 and
there's there's not been I don't think
one person he's probably had as much of
an impact on my career as him I think
well I wouldn't I'd say I would not have
won London 2012 if it wasn't for him I
think I'm gonna say exactly the same
thing like my coach was literally
like he was just that guy like I
remember actually when I first joined
them
um so he was called Brian but I used to
call him Mr scoby and I was like
terrified of him like I was so scared of
him but like eventually like we just
ended up with like this real like
I used to call him Grandad and he used
to hate it like
um but we it just was like this real
fatherly figure like in my life
um he'd like my mum used to love him
because like he'd take me to
competitions I could you know make sure
I got home and I literally just like
loved this guy there was times I had
absolute meltdowns I'd just be crying
and me and my training partner would
have had a massive argument and I'm just
sat there crying 100 in the wrong but
trying to come up and be like all right
you know let's go for an ice cream or
something and he just was like a great
guy I mean he also coached me really
well I'm forgetting all that the
influencer but like he just like every
year like I just got better and better
and better and then in 2014 when I get
got ill
um it was actually a really cute video
of like me doing like a drill session
and like my arm doing like I have like
annoying spasms and that my arm was
doing something weird and he just kind
of grabbed it and he was like rubbing it
and he was like is this what we've got
now and I just thought yeah and he was
like okay let's crack on he then took me
from you know being this able-bodied
athlete to be in this not so great
person with this disability that I was
trying to like get my head around
um and he then reinvented me as like a
new athlete mum and dad
[Music]
they can continuously but trust me to
keep keep going every day and and my
coaches
no no
no not really
um
pushed me in and and
it's it's that not
keep keeps me going yeah
is there anything you you currently do
outside of sport that you'd like to do
more of I I
do yeah
uh Jones of
sports stadiums I think that um
Special Olympics
um
called not now guy yeah for me obviously
I have a little boy already I have
another one coming so I feel like my
life and actually I never sit still so
it all is a bit Carnage I've basically
just set up a pet and farm at my house
um so I've got alpacas sheep chickens
rabbits you name it I've got a lot so
that's going to take up plenty of my
time
um but also yeah I mean
oh see we don't know what our careers
are going to end do we but um
I've never had any sort of
of a career path as such in terms of
I've never thought oh when I finish I'll
be an accountant or whatever like I
started cycling for such a young age I
never really got into anything else as
such for me it's maybe about helping
that next Generation like
probably like the 14 year old you know
14 16 year olds
um and getting more of them somehow I
don't know how but getting more of them
riding bikes and getting them into
you know the junior ranks um bringing
more athletes through because I just
think it's such a shame for a sport that
I love so much it seems that we're
getting less riders coming through
currently so yeah just doing something
to give back I guess to British cycling
because they are well cycling as a whole
but British cycling has given me so much
that I kind of want to give back to them
without being a coach I'm not doing that
I'm not being that athlete but I mean
Jason's done it and it's stressful I'm
not doing that laughs
I get like the the giving back thing I
set up a cycling Academy to get
more people from a black and ethnic
minority in cycling like I feel like you
know it's acting like it's very white
middle class male predominantly and it's
nice when we've actually got a few
female coaches in there
um but after uh kind of I've always
wanted to do something like that because
I would have never got into cycling had
I not fallen into it
um because I just didn't see myself as a
cyclist so I I'm working at the moment
to try and get more people from those
backgrounds into cycling
um just to yeah give back that little
bit Yeah your farm basically sounds like
the dream yeah
it's quite fun but I'm scared that I
won't eat meat afterwards you know what
I mean it's much meat so it's like the
chickens are Jason's yeah I don't know
if I would I'd struggle like lack of
protein you don't need it if you're not
an athlete so I might get away with it
but yeah I'd love to like have so many
animals and rescue and that is that's
definitely been a dream for a long time
what advice would you give to any
um aspiring athlete or the beginning of
their career go forward take every
opportunity that comes to you with both
hands and if you can find the support
that suits you fabulous if not then find
somebody who will know the answer and if
they don't know I'm sure they all know
somebody who will know the answer now
what do you think okay give give her any
spot or go
and have a try
and
don't don't give up on that Journey as
well I would definitely say the same
like try absolutely any sport I think
there's you don't know what you're good
at until you fall apart and unless you
try you just don't know also don't be
scared to ask questions like I've always
been a person just to
question everything basically like it's
not if I think something I'd rather ask
it and look like an idiot then not ask
it at all because I just think well I'm
either going to get information or I'm
not and I'd rather risk you know maybe
asking a silly question than not then
maybe get information that I actually
need and we'll take further in my career
I would say just simply enjoy the ride
um because we're so like all of us are
so lucky to almost be the best in our
Sport and
for me personally I don't think I've
ever taken enough time to actually kind
of realize what I've done and also in
the in the moments as well to actually
think oh hang on a minute this is
actually well good like I'm enjoying it
sort of thing so just kind of
remembering you know what you're doing
how lucky you were and just enjoying it
enjoyment's always been the biggest
thing I think I agree with you so much
there I think
you've got to be quite dedicated to be
obviously an Elite Sports person and I
think for me the biggest thing that's
helped with that is is it's been fun I
love what I do every day you know I love
going to training so all the little kids
out there I remember like you know when
you're at the track and you see some
parents that are maybe pushing their
kids towards the sport should we say and
you hear how they talk to their kids and
stuff and these kids are not enjoying
training and you're just like please
like that kid's never going to be like
they're never going to be able to take
it to the elite level so it's just
remember what you're doing and remember
it's it's fun yeah
the Champions League final comes around
at that point you're playing Spurs how
confident were you going into that we
knew 100 we knew like there was no way
that they beat us there was no way we
knew we were the much better team